reclaim hong kong they chant
and hong kong people unite
[Applause]
these pro-democracy campaigners should
be voting today
in elections to the city's legislature
instead they're out on the streets after
authorities delayed the poll until next
summer
citing a spike in covet 19 cases
but their protests have been met with an
armed response
with police firing pepper balls at some
and using stop and search on others
[Applause]
the new national security law imposed by
china
bans demonstrations like these
another reason people are protesting
right now the protest is uh is spent
by the hong kong government so we
we have to fight for the space to
voice out what we care what we want to
talk about
i think the hong kong government is here
to suppress people's
rights to express their demands about
what the future should look like
our rights are being abused
opposition activist is one of dozens
arrested
he's accused of using seditious words
which are
also banned
pro-democracy campaigners began taking
to the streets in june last year
the recent government crackdown means
many are now keeping their views to
themselves
but sunday's protest proves some in hong
kong
will not go quietly
[Music]
and dw's correspondent phoebe kong joins
us from hong kong now
phoebe hundreds of people are protesting
there today against the postponing
of the elections what exactly are they
worried about
i'm now standing at the streets where
police have deployed
pepper pellets to disperse protesters
hours ago
and uh now some skeptics protesters and
now they've been announced as chanting
slogans on the street
not leaving but um their main like
demands is that they
they want to protest against the
decision of the government to postpone
the legislative election
for a year so um the government said
this
is for the sake of public health reasons
and also
to uh help to contain coronal virus
pandemic but
this is an uh reason seen as an excuse
by the protesters and pro-democracy
campaign
so they are very much angry about this
decision so they
go out today to protest against it and
also apart from that
many of them also wanted to want to
express the anger towards the
newly implemented national security law
which has already been
imposed for more than two months so um
this is like
one of the reasons they why they come
out today to define the ban of the
police and also to
chess tokens of like which are seen now
banned by the authority
so it's a general mistrust for this
government clearly we understand
protesters have been
arrested what else can you tell us
well you have mentioned in the report at
least 90 people have been arrested
during the rally today in the afternoon
local time but
earlier before the rally uh a leader of
an opposition
party tim takshi was arrested by police
for
suspicions words so a police accused him
of uh
spreading hatred and inciting contempt
against the government
so um this is uh the this is uh the
investigation and the arrest was
conducted by
the national security unit under the
police force
and they admit that they originally they
want to
precede the case under the charges of
the national security law but later on
they found um
another like offense is more appropriate
charges but anyway
um critics say this is pretty much what
they see as
speech crimes like the authorities want
to use to target the opposition takers
phoebe we have about 15 or 20 seconds
besides the arrest that
that we have seen at this point has
there been any other reaction from hong
kong authorities
well the government has denied any
accusation towards the
delay of the postponement they've said
this is not going
this is not politically motivated this
is for the sake of public health
and for like we have seen the rally
today has been laid descended in a
little bit chaos so
we will expect that the authority will
condemn and criticize the rally
held today as they sting is unauthorized
phoebe kong much appreciated